let's say that you don't like company
ABCD that's right now trading for $50 a
share but you don't have the stomach to
short the stock because there's a
possibility that you could lose an
infinite amount of money if you short it
you still have an option quite literally
you still have an option you can buy a
put option once again we're dealing with
the American variation and just like an
American call option an American put
option gives you the the right to
exercise the option anytime before the
expiration date a European call or put
option you can only exercise on the
expiration date and the situation with a
put option a call option allowed gave
you the right to buy the stock at a
specified price a put option is the
opposite it gives you the right to sell
the stock at a specified price so this
little made up put option I I said I've
constructed right here it's maybe being
sold on in exchange for five dollars per
option and it gives you the right it
gives you the right to sell company ABCD
at $40 a share anytime over the next
month and let's see how if you were to
buy this how this really is a bet that
the company would go down so let's
imagine the scenario where the company
does what you expect it goes down and
one month later you just keeps going
down you're like well I better use it
today because it's going to expire if I
don't use it today so you you exercise
the option right over there and so what
this allows you to do is sell the the
stock at $40 and if you don't own it
that's okay because you could go and buy
the stock right now on the market you
knew it was going to get cheaper so you
can buy it for $20 and then exercise
your option and sell it for 40 so you're
buying it 20 and immediately selling for
40 so you're going to be making $20 and
then if you subtract out the price that
you had to pay for the option you're
going to have a 15 dollar profit you're
going to have a 15 dollar profit over
here let me scroll over to the right so
you have some space and this is of
course the situation with the put option
this is
is the put option and if your bet goes
against you and the stock actually goes
up it's not going to be like a short
position where you can lose an unlimited
amount of money in that situation let's
say let's say the stock just keeps going
up and up and up and up well at any
point above $40 is like you know there's
no point in me exercising the option so
you just let it expire so in that
situation you just wasted your money
buying the actual option so you just
lose you just lose the actual $5 even if
that stock were to go up to a gazillion
dollars you're not required to buy it
back like you would if you were shorting
it you can just let the option expire